ก็
สวัสดีครับครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะคืนนี้เจอกัน
อีกแล้วนะคะ
สวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนด้วยสวัสดีนักเรียน
ทุกคนค่ะ
ชอบลืมชอบลืมนักเรียนสวัสดีคือให้โทษ
สวัสดีครูสบายดีไหมเราขอคุยไปสักพักแล้ว
ก็ลืมนักเรียน
ไม่เป็นไรนักเรียนคุยกับเราให้นักเรียนดู
เราเดี๋ยวสวัสดีตอนจบ
ครูเอ๋สบายดีไหมครับเอ่อคิดว่า
ทำไมทำไมคิดว่าสบายดีแต่ว่าถือว่าตอนนี้
กูเอชอบกินอะไรที่ทอดอ่ะคุณนี้รู้จักก่อน
ใช่มั้ยก็จะตายอย่างเงี้ยเป็นตายมีโดนัท
พรุ่งนี้ใช่ไหมที่มีน้ำมันๆน้ำมันเยอะๆขอ
โทษแล้วกูอ่ะ
I
[เพลง]
กลัว Hack  Shield กลัวเป็นหวัดนะเอกก็
ไม่
อ๋อ
อ่อนี่โอเคโอเคเห็นไหมคะเห็นครับเห็น
นักเรียนจะชัดไหมอ่ะโอเคผลไม้ใช่ไหมครับ
ได้ผลไม้
เปรี้ยวมั้ยเออชื่อมะขามป้อมมะขามป้อม
โอเคโอเคเพราะมันเป็นป้อมๆเนาะ
มีไว้จะ minzy มากๆคนอื่นก็เลยต้อง
1 ลูก 1 วันไงเนี่ยปล่อยนิดหน่อย
ก็มีน้ำน้ำ
[เพลง]
บ่อน้ำร้อน
มะนาว
โอเคโอเคก็
ขอให้หายไวๆ
เสียงโอเคนะโอเคอยู่โอเคอยู่โอเคนะค่ะอ้า
เดี๋ยวเรามาดูวันที่กันดีกว่าค่ะขาวๆเออ
เดี๋ยวผู้เหนสกรีนแชร์หน้าจอใช่ไหมให้ค่ะ
ค่ะคุณเอ็กซ์เห็นไหมเห็นไหมครับเห็นแท็ก
mi หน้านี้ก่อนนะคะ
โอเคมั้ยโอเคครับโอเคเออวันนี้วันอะไร
ครับวันนี้ล่ะคะวันนี้วันนี้วันพฤหัสเนาะ
วันพฤหัสบดี
วันพฤหัสบดีฉาบวันที่เท่าไหร่ครับวันที่
19 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรครับเดือน
คำคมค่ะ
ปีคศอะไรครับ
2,000  22 ค่ะ
แล้วปีพตอะไรครับ 2 คัน
565 ค่ะโอเค
555 ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะคุณนิที่อเมริกา
อเมริกาที่คุณนิคอยู่ตอนนี้
8:00 น 23 ครับตอนเช้า
8:00  23 นะคะจ่าย 8:00 น 8:00 นครับ
แล้วที่ไทยกี่โมงครับที่พายก็
20:00 น
23 นาทีค่ะขอเบอร์
12 ชั่วโมงห่างกันนะครับ 12 ชั่วโมงห่าง
การที่อเมริกาจะช้ากว่า
ที่ประเทศไทยอเมริกาวันอะไรคะวันเดียวกัน
ครับแต่แค่ว่าเป็นตอนเช้าเช้านะคะอ๋อของ
กูเอ๋เพื่อรหัสตอนเย็นหน้ากาก
จริงๆที่อเมริกาเนี่ยต้องบอกไว้ก่อนว่า
เวลามันไม่เหมือนกันอย่างบ้าอะไรเนี่ย
เหมือนกันทั้งประเทศใช่ไหมครับค่ะอเมริกา
นะไม่ใช่อ๋อมีรัฐรัฐใช่ไหมแคลิฟอร์เนีย
ถูกมั้ยว่าชิงกันที่ 4
คู่เอกฟาริด้าดอกใช่ครับหรือแมสซาชูเซตส์
ก็ของคุณวิรัชจะเป็นรัฐรัฐครับแล้วก็มัน
ก็จะอยู่แบ่งเป็นโซนเป็นที่ที่ว่าเวลามัน
ไม่เหมือนกันของคุณอย่างจะอยู่ตรงกลางเรา
ต้องการจะช้ากว่าที่ไทย 12 ชั่วโมง
ชาร์จถ้าบางทีก็ 13 เหรอคะใช่ครับบางทีก็
13 คุณนิดงงแล้ว 13 ก็ตามใช่ครับสหาย
โอเคเอาเอกก็เพิ่งรู้นะๆ
กี่โมงกี่โมงขอบคุณค่ะคุณเอ็กซ์ผมบอกไว้
ก่อนว่าไม่งั้นเดี๋ยวนักเรียนดูแล้วงงว่า
เอ๊ะอเมริกามันใหญ่เวลาไม่เหมือนกันครับ
ของคุณนิดอยู่ร้านอะไรคะคุณนิคเมื่ออยู่
ร้าน with คอนเซนครับอ่าก็ห่างจากไทย 12
ชั่วโมงๆชายขับถ้าคุณนิคอยู่อเมริกาคิด
ถึงประเทศไทยไหมคะคิดถึงอาหารไทย
ถ้าคุณนี่บอกไม่คิดถึงกูเอกจะบอกวันนี้
ต้องคิดถึงๆคิดถึงอาหารไทยคิดถึงที่
เที่ยวในไทยด้วยครับคุณนี้บางทีเบื่อคุณ
นี้จะชอบไปแถวสนามหลวงแถว
แถวโรงพยาบาลศิริราช
ชายโอเควันนี้ครูเอ๋จะพาคนนี้ไปเที่ยว
ประเทศไทย
ถ้าคนไทยไปเที่ยวประเทศไทยได้คนไทยมา
เที่ยวประเทศไทย
พานักเรียนด้วยฐานนักเรียนมาเที่ยวประเทศ
ไทยนะคะหาที่นี่เลยคุณนิครู้จักไหมคะรู้
ให้สะอาดหรือทักแน่นอนกับ
คนไทยน่ะคนไทยนะนักเรียนอ่าคนไทยเรียกว่า
อะไรคะคนไทยเรียกว่าวัดพระแก้วถ้าเรียก
ชื่อง่ายๆนะใช่สอนไทยเรียกวัดพระแก้วแต่
คนต่างชาติไม่เรียกวัดพระแก้ว
คนต่างซ่าเรียกว่าอะไรคนต่างชาติน่ะไม่
ได้คิดถึงวัดอ่ะว่าที่นี่มีบ้านตรงนี้ใช่
ไหมคะตรงนี้หน่ะข้างหลังวัดพระแก้วมีบ้าน
เป็นบ้านของในหลวงรักในหลวงครับเป็นขอบสี
ดำนะคะเอาสีน้ำเงินดีกว่า
ขอโทษค่ะ
เปลี่ยนนะคะลบอ่ะ
เธอเป็นบ้าในหลวงราคะ
ในหลวงก็คือพระราชาใช้ไม่ราชานะคะในหลวง
ก็ได้หลวงในหลวงที่กรุงเทพฯตั้งแต่รัชกาล
ที่ 1 คุณนิค่ะ
รัชกาลที่ 1 ถึง 5 เนี่ยก็จะอยู่ที่นี่
เนาะ
อยู่ที่คุยก็เป็นบ้านนะคะบ้านในหลวงนัก
เรียนก็จะจะเรียกว่าภาษาไทยยาว
โอเคแต่ต้องพูดนะคะ
โอเคฟังดีๆนะคะพระบ่บ่รมมมะหา
ราชวัง
R8 คำพระบรมมาหา
จะพูดเร็วๆพระบรมมหาราชวังมือชื่อถ้าเรา
นอกเธอช้าๆพระ
บรมมหาราชวังชาย
ฝั่งก็ลืมแล้ว
แต่คนไทยน่ะเข้าไปจะไปที่ตรงนี้ลงตรงนี้
ตรงนี้นะคะตอนนี้
ตรงนี้ที่เราเรียกว่าวัดพระแก้วนะคะ
แก้วเป็นวัดที่ไม่มีพระนะคะเอ้าไม่มีพระ
เป็นคนล่ะค่ะโอเคคุณนี้ก็งงเอ๊ะไม่มีพระ
แล้วทำไมเรียกวัดพระแก้วก็ก็มีมีพระแก้ว
โอเค
พระแก้วมรกตนะคะ
พระพระพุทธรูปเนาะเราได้พระพุทธรูปสีอะไร
คะสีคของเรานะครับสีครามสีเขียวตรงนี้นะ
คะเอ๊ย
นิสีเปลี่ยนสีนะคะเนี่ยสีเขียว
สีเขียวเนาะเรียกว่าพระแก้วมรกตนะคะชื่อ
พระแก้วมรกต
โอเคแอปตัวเองก็จะมีรูปให้ดูนิดนึงอ้ะจะ
นะข้างในวัดพระแก้วอุมิยักษ์ด้วยนะคุณนี้
อะอย่าเปรียบ
ยักษ์นะคะแล้วก็กลับมาตรงนี้ตรงนี้ก็จะมี
เจดีย์เนาะมีเจดีย์นะครับ
วันนี้วันนี้คนไทยเวลาคนไทยไปน่ะคนไทยก็
จะไปไหว้พระแก้วมรกตนะคะไหนครับช่วยเข้า
ไปใช่ไหมคะเคยครับเคยเข้าไปแต่คูนิสไป
แล้วคนเยอะมากฮ่าๆใช่วัดพระแก้วคนเยอะ
อยู่ตลอดครับไทยหรือคนต่างชาติ
คนต่างชาติครับใช่แต่ก็มีคนทางเองครับคน
ไทยก็มีเป็นนักเรียนเป็นด่างครับเขาก็จะ
ชอบโรงเรียนจะชอบพาเด็กๆไปวัดพระแก้วคำ
เพราะว่าที่วัดพระแก้วคุณนิเห็นไหมคะข้าง
หลังโน้ตให้ตรงเนี้ยมีฉากมาหาภาพวาดตกตรง
นี้มาฝาผนังนะคะอ่ะฝาผนังก็จะมีภาพวาดสวย
นะคะอันนี้ข้างในวัดพระแก้วนะคะจากข้าง
นอกนักเรียนคะข้างนอกรอบตรงนี้ค่ะคุณนี้
เรารอบนี้เลยเดินมาเลยค่ะเดินมาตลอด
ถึงที่นี่ครับนี่เลยค่ะเป็นสี่เหลี่ยมเลย
ก็มีภาพวาดไม่ใช่ๆถ้าคุณนิดจะไม่ผิดก็มี
ว่าพอเข้าไปข้างในใช่ไหมครับมันก็จะมี
กำแพงยาวๆมันก็จะมีภาพวาด 3 ผนังเหมือน
กันมีตัวเองมีรูปให้ดูนี่ไงอันนี้เลยครับ
ใช่ๆตั้งจะเป็นภาพวาดฝาผนังและรูปนี้ไม่
ค่อยชัดน้าๆนี่นี่เลยโอเคอ่ะ
อันนี้เป็นรูปขอโอเคโอเค
อ่าเห็นไหมคะเห็นครับเห็นนี่ก็เป็นรูปภาพ
วาดที่ฝาผนังวัดพระแก้วนะคะ
คืนนี้
เวลาดูอันนี้เข้าใจไหมใครทำอะไรคุณดีก่า
เห็นรูปเนี่ยนะจะนึกถึงตัวหนังสือเรียน
ภาษาไทย
น่ารักๆใช่คนไม่ผิดเนี่ย
ที่ข้างล่างด้านขวาเนี่ยจะเป็นหนุมานหรือ
เปล่า
นี่เลยซื้อ
อันนี้เป็นลิง not ลิงสีขาวนะคะลิงสีขาว
คือหนุมานเก่งมากค่ะคุณนี้นะคะ 8 คู่เอก
อ้อมคู่เอกก็ไม่รู้ว่าอ่ะคนนี้นี่คาราม
หรือพระรักนะคะแต่ในรูปเนี้ยนักเรียนจะ
เห็นก็คือ 1 ลิงขับ
สองคน
อันนี้คือคนนะคะอันนี้คือลิงสาอันนี้ก็
เหลิ่งธนาคะ 3 ยักษ์กับนิยะก็มีเขี้ยวหมี
เขี้ยวนะ
มีเขี้ยวนะคะอันนี้ลิงตัวนี้ชื่ออะไรนะคะ
หันหนุมานครับหนูมารวันนี้เราจะมารู้จัก
หนุมาน
โอเคครับมีค่าในวัดพระแก้วในวัดพระแก้วนะ
คะก็จะมีรูปหนุมานใหญ่ๆอย่างนี้เลยคืนนี้
อันนี้มีแม่น้ำใช่ไหมคะเวลานักเรียนเดิน
เดินแล้วก็ดูนะกูไม่สนุกเข้าใจมีแม่น้ำ
แล้วก็มีหนุมานหนุมานตัวเล็กก็ได้ตัวใหญ่
ก็ได้โอเคนะคุณนิคจำไม่ได้คุณนี้เข็นตัว
ใหญ่คืนนี้ก็งงว่าเอ๊ะทำไมเมื่อกี้ยังตัว
เล็กแล้วอันนี้ตัวใหญ่แล้ว
อนุมานมีอิทธิฤทธิ์เราเรียกว่าอิทธิฤทธิ์
อาหารค่ะขออนุมานตัวเล็กได้ตัวใหญ่ได้
ครับเพราะเหมือน Superman ได้
จำน้ำได้ทำได้หลายอย่างเนาะ
แล้วก็ไม่ตาย
โอเค
หนุมานเนี่ยที่นี่มีแม่น้ำใช่ไหมคะรูปนี้
หนุมานก็ทำตัวใหญ่แล้วบอกแปลงร่างจากตัว
เล็กเป็นตัวใหญ่มาให้ชายแล้วก็ให้อันนี้
มีรถคุยให้ดูใกล้ๆ
เดี๋ยวนะคุณนี้ก็เห็นไหมพยายามจะขยายนี้
เหมือนเห็นมีเพื่อนเป็นรถสีทองอยู่บนหลัง
ใช่ไหมหลังหนุมานวันนี้ค่ะนี่ใหญ่ไหมใหญ่
พอไหมใหญ่ก็เห็นแล้วครับเห็นเรา
ก็มีไม่มีรถใช้หากตัวนี้เรา
เรียกว่าราชรถใช่ไหมคะคุณนี้ว่าสระรถครับ
ๆ
ณชรตก็ขึ้นหลังหนุมานข้ามแม่น้ำนะแล้วก็
ตัวนี้ก็มีลิงลิงก็เดินเดินเดิน
ข้ามแม่น้ำไม่ต้องมีสะพาน
ไม่ต้องมีสะพานมีหนุมานโอเคก็ดีฟ้าเห็นจะ
ดูสนุกนะคืนนี้จะข้ามอยากฆ่าแม่น้ำคุณมี
เครียดหนุมานมาดีกว่าแล้วก็ไม่ทัน
[เพลง]
ไม่ได้
อนุมานไม่ทำงานให้คน
โอเคอนุมานทำงานให้
ให้คนนี้ค่ะพระราม
โอเคโอเคถ้าเป็นไม่ถ้า
ไม่ทำงานให้คุณนิไม่ทำงานให้ครูเอ๋อะ
โอเคอ่ะมีหนุมานแล้วนะเดี๋ยวคุยให้ดูอีก
นะคะอันนี้ก็หนุมานอีกนะคะ
แบตตัวใหญ่มากช้าปากเป็นบ้านเขาไทยไอ้ลิง
ให้ให้โอนี้คนนี้ชื่อพระรามนภารามรามอยู่
ข้างในอ๋อโอเคเข้าไปนอนได้นะคะ
อันนี้ก็หนุมาน
นักเรียนก็จะเห็นละหนุมานหนุมานเป็นใครมา
จากไหน
ทำไมอยู่กับข้านามทำไมทำงานให้พระรามสาย
พระรามเป็นใครอ่ะฮ่าๆๆนักเรียนจำได้นนทก
นักเรียนไปดูคลิปที่แล้วนะคะเก็บที่แล้ว
ที่
ค่ะวันนี้นะคะนักเรียนผู้เอกก็จะให้นัก
เรียนรู้จักค่ะนุมานนะคะ
ทำไมเป็นเป็นหนุมานหนุมานเป็นใครก่อนอื่น
เนี่ยคุณนิค
อนุมานทำไมไม่ตายอ้ะทำไมไม่มี
คนเล็กอ่ะ
จำไม่ได้จำไม่ได้ไม่เป็นไรคิดว่านะเก๋บอก
โอเค
กูบอกเมื่อก่อนยังไม่มีหนุมานครับมีมี
ฤาษีอันนี้เป็นฤาษี
นะฮะฤาษี
ฤาษีนะชื่อ
ฤาษีโคดมครับฤาษีโคดมฤาษีโคดมเนี่ยเมื่อ
ก่อนเป็น
เสือพระราชา
โอเคครับแล้วเป็นผ้าชาดีนะแล้วฤาษีก็
เบื่อเป็นพระราชาออกมา
บวชเป็นฤาษีอ๋อ
ไม่โกนหนวด
อันนี้นะไม่โกนหนวดหนวดเนี่ยคุณนิหนวดตรง
นี้ใช่ไหมคะหนวดยาวสีขาวใช่ไหมครับง่าย
จริงๆโหลดเขายาวมากคุณนิ
ฤาษีคู่ได้มีคำถามว่าฤาษีฤาษีเนื้อเค้าจะ
อยู่ที่ไหนครับอยู่ในป่าค่ะอ๋อโอเคอยู่ใน
ป่าวอ้อมเขา
เขาเบื่อแล้วไปเป็นฤาษีฤาษีหลวงพ่อฤาษีก็
เหมือนเค้กให้กับพระใช่หมอนัดยายป่า
เขาจะอยู่ในป่าแต่ว่าเขาจะใส่ชุดไม่
เหมือนพระหน้าเราก็คิดมีอะไรไม่เหมือนพระ
จะหรือสีเนี่ยอ้ามากๆจะนั่งแบบนี้เราจะ
อยู่คนเดียวไม่ใหญ่เหลือใครใช่ไหมนั่งนาน
ๆสีคนนั่งนานมากไม่ขยับ
จนตัวนี้คนนี้เห็นนกไหมคะครับ
นกเนี่ยหานกมีนก 2 ตัว
นกกระจาบ
นกกระจาบมาแคร์นกกระจาบ 2 ตัวเนี่ยก็เลย
มาทำรัง
ก็ฤาษีไม่ขยับเนาะอยู่นิ่งๆเขย่าก็เลยเอา
หนวดฤาษีนะมาทำหลังอันนี้ใช้หนวดโอเคนวล
ถ้า
เกิดกูเองไม่มีรูปหนวดฤาษีแล้วนกกระจาบ 2
ตัวก็
อยู่ที่นี่
คุณนิคนะคิดว่านกอะไม่รู้ว่าเป็นฤาษี
เพราะว่าอยู่นิ่งแบบไม่ขยับก็เลยนึกว่า
เอสซีคงเป็นก็มีแค่ฉันที่ไหนวะอ้วนนกรู้
ไหม
นกไม่น่าจะรู้นะนั่นน่ะสิคุยไม่แน่ใจว่า
นกรู้ไหมครับ
นก 2 ตัวแต่งงานกัน 5
ครับมีมีนกตัวผู้
นกอันนี้เป็นนกตัวนี้เป็นผู้ชายต้องตัว
ผู้ค่ะนกตัวผู้หญิง - ผู้หญิงผมยาวหน่อย
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
นกไม่มีผม
สมมติเอาเป็นว่าตายผู้หญิงราย
การเรายังไงต่อครับนานกสองตัวก็อยู่ที่
นี่ใช่ไหมคะภูเอานกเองไปอยู่ที่นี่ก่อนนะ
คะ
[เพลง]
2 ตัวก็รักกันนะคะรักกันดี
ๆสีก็อยู่เฉยๆนกก็อยู่ที่นี่มีอยู่วันนึง
วันหนึ่งนกตัวผู้นะค่ะนกตัวเมียเขามีไข่
เนาะไข่ก็อยู่ที่นี่นกตัวผู้ก็บิน
บินออกไปเราก็คุยหาสีชมพู่ก่อน
อะนกบินอยู่อะบิลละบินไปไกล
เลยคนนี่โอ้โอ๋
แล้วก็ไปเจอดอกบัวครับ
ดอกบัว
นกตัวผู้ก็อยู่ในนี้อ่ะโอ้นี่นี่นกตัวผู้
และหาอาหารอาหารคิดเอาอาหารกลับบ้านให้นก
ตัวเมียนะคะให้นกตัวเมียปรากฏว่า
อ่ะนกตัวผู้ก็กินกินอาหารเก็บไว้แต่มัน
มืดดอกบวมปิดอ้าว
พี่นกวันที่หนึ่งดอกบัวสิให้มันก็ออกไม่
ได้บินไม่ได้กินในดอกบัวทำไม่ได้เพราะมัน
มันก็ปิดมันก็ออกไม่ได้ต้องรอจนดอกบัว
เปิดแล้วก็ออกมาหล่อๆรอจะรอนานไหมเนี่ยรอ
นานเล็กนอนๆนานนกตัวเมียอยู่ที่บ้านผู้
หญิงอ่ะผู้หญิงครับคุณนี้สามีนกแต่งงาน
แล้วใช่ไหมสามีไปไม่กลับบ้านโกรธมั้ยโกรธ
สิโกแล
สามีไปไหนไปหาใครหรือเปล่าทำไมไม่กลับ
บ้านและ
โกรธมากนะ
แล้วยังไงต่อครับเพราะก่อนนกตัวผู้กลับมา
นกตัวผู้เมียก็โกรธก็ไปไหนมา
อยู่ดีๆ
สามีตกใจตกใจก็บอกไปหาอาหารแต่ดอกบัวปิด
นกตัวเมียไม่เชื่อโกหกใช่ไหม
ทำผิดไปมีนกผู้หญิงนกตัวเมียที่ 2 ใช่ไหม
เป็นนกเจ้าชู้ใช่ไหมสู้ๆ
ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่บริษัทกันทะเลาะกันใช่ไหม
หรือสีอะไรเนี่ยนกก็ทะเลาะกันเมื่อก่อน
อยู่เฉยๆโอเคนก 2 ตัวรักกันแต่ตอนนี้นก
ทะเลาะกันหรือสีก็นั่งสมัครอะไรเนี่ยแล้ว
นกพูดได้นักเรียนโนะพูดได้นกตัวผู้ก็บอก
ไม่ได้โกหก
นกตัวไม่บอกสาบานสิบอกไม่ได้โกหกสาบาน
ชั้นมี
ขอตัวเมียตัวที่สองชั้นผิด
ผิดน่ะเป็นบาปคนไทยบอกบาปมีภรรยาหนึ่ง
ภรรยา 2 ไม่ได้ปลาบ
ตัวผู้ก็บอกบาปฉันเนี่ยให้ไปที่ฤาษี
เครื่องฤาษีฤาษีงงเกี่ยวอะไร
คุณให้หัวรีสีเลยกำลังนั่งสมาธินกทะเลาะ
กันเสร็จแล้วบอกบาปเนี่ยให้มาสินะ
ถ้าคุณนี้เป็นฤาษีได้คืน
เกี่ยวอะไรทำไมทะเลาะกันแล้วทำไมต้องมา
เกี่ยวกับเรื่องสีด้วย
คุณนิคจะลืมตามาถามไหมทำไมคนนี้ก็ลืมตา
แน่นอนเฮ้ยทำไมเกี่ยวอะไรด้วยเนี่ยเก่ง
มากคู่นี้หรือสีก็ลืมตาจะถามทำไมบาปมาที่
ฉัน
ทำอะไรโยนโยนเอาความผิดมาให้
ฤาษีไม่เกี่ยวอยู่ก็อยู่ที่หนวดฤาษีใช่
มั้ยฮะเอ้อๆ
นกตัวผู้ก็บอกว่าก็ฤาษีเป็นคนบาป
1 สีถามฉันคนดีบาปอะไร
บาปอะไรเอ้ย
นกตัวผู้ก็บอกฤาษีเป็นในหลวง
เออ
มีเมืองใหญ่ๆครับไม่ทำงานครับไม่ทำงานมา
เป็นหรือสีแล้วก็
ไม่ไม่ได้แต่งงานเข้าไม่มีลูก
ไม่มีลูกไม่ทำหน้าที่ในหลวง
มีพระราชานักเรียนพระราชา
พระราชาในหลวงเหมือนกันนะคะไม่ทำหน้าที่
ตัวเองครับบาปใหญ่บาป
ไม่รู้น๊ะถ้านกกันจะอาบว่าคุณนี้อย่าง
นั้นทำอะไรดีคนเล็กน่าจะกินนกเลย
อะสีไม่กินน้อแต่ก็ดีก็เถอะใช่อย่างนะถ้า
คุณนี้เป็นพระฤาษีนะคุณนี้ก็จะ
คุณนี้ก็จะบอกว่าพูดแบบนี้ได้ยังไงชายพูด
ไม่ดีๆพูดนี้ดีเพราะพูดแบบนี้โกรธใช่
อะฤาษีก็คิดโอ้เออจริงผ้าฤาษีนั่งนานๆก็
ไม่มีลูกให้นกมาว่าพระฤาษีก็เลยลุกขึ้นมา
ก็คือนี้ครับไปอาบน้ำ
ฮะ
โอเคอาบน้ำอาบน้ำไปอาบน้ำโกนหนวด
หนวดยาวใช่มั้ยโกนดวดผมทำความสะอาดให้ของ
หอมได้นกอยู่ได้ไหมคะอยู่ไม่ได้เสียนกก็
ไปเลย
คนหนวดบ้านหาย
ไม่มีที่อยู่พูดไม่ดีใช่ไหม
คะหรือสิก็คงบอกว่าได้พูดไม่ดี
เอาบ้านดอกเลย
คือพระนี่สีเขาคิดอย่างนี้ค่ะคุณนี้เขา
คิดว่าเออเขาก็ไม่มีรูปอันนี้ผิดจริงใช่
ไหมคะภายในสีก็เลยถ้าจะแต่งงานก็ต้องอาบ
น้ำให้หอมๆโกนหนวดหน้านกก็ไม่มีบ้านแล้ว
เน้อไม่มีบ้านแล้วตอนนี้จะเอาไปไว้ที่ต้น
ไม้ถ้าตัวเองไม่รู้นะเขาบอกแค่โกนหนวด
แต่พระฤาษีก็อยู่ในป่าผู้หญิงที่ไหนอ่ะ
ไม่มีผู้หญิงท่าฤาษีก็เลยออทำพิธีโอ
มีไฟที่นี่ครับ 7 มีไฟ
แล้วก็สีก็ OO จงมีผู้หญิงผู้หญิง
ก็เลยมีผู้หญิงสวยมามาก
ผู้หญิงสวย
คิดคิดว่าคลิปนี้ไม่จบ
ไม่เป็นมีผู้หญิงสวยขึ้นมาจากไฟ
[เพลง]
โอเคก็เลยชื่อคนนี้นะคะจริงๆค่ะมี 2 ชื่อ
ครับบางคน 1 นางกานต์นางอะค่ะว่าผู้หญิง
ข่าวงานอัจนา
บางคนเรียก
นางการอัดคีย์อ๋ออัคคีก็คือไฟใช่มั้ยไป
น่ะไปน่ะเรียกอัคคีแต่บางคนก็เล่นอัจนา
กาลอัจนาการอัดขี่โอเคสวยมากเฮ้อโอเคโอเค
พระฤาษีกับนางกาลอัจนาก็แต่งงานค่ะ
Happy  Ending ใช่ไหมคะก็ดูจะ Happy
Ending นะเพราะว่าก็พระฤาษีก็มีผู้หญิง
แล้วแต่งงานก็อยู่ด้วยกันใช่แล้วก็มีลูก
สาวด้วยคือนิลูกสาวลูกสาวชื่ออะไรครับที่
สว่างหัก
สวาหะ OK อาอ้าอ้าวพี่ลูกสาวชื่อสวาหะโอ้
เป็นครอบครัวมีความสุขมากอบแล้วพ่อแม่ลูก
ค้าก็มีบ้านเนาะตอนนี้ก็เป็นมีบ้าน
ออกบ้านหรือสิเค้าเรียกว่าอาส่งมาเนาะมึง
อาศรมครับ
แล้วที่นี้เนี่ยพระฤาษีนะก็ชอบนั่งสมาธิ
อร่อย
นั่งสมาธิบางทีพระฤาษีก็โอ้มีลูกแล้วโอเค
ไม่ไม่บาปแล้วมีลูกก็กลับไปนั่งสมาธิต่อ
ใช่บางทีก็ไปนั่งในป่าไปไกลๆโอเคโอเคไปไป
ในในภูเขาฮัลโหลมีต้นไม้ท่าฤาษีราคาภาษี
เนี้ยก็ไป
แล้วไปแบบนี้ภรรยา
พบกับลูบไม่สงสัยหรอไม่คิดหรอว่าเอ๋ทำไม
ไม่อยู่บ้านพันศรีบอกอ๋ออ๋ออ๋อ
เดี๋ยวไปนับอาจจะไปนั่งสมาธิอ่ะไปแล้วก็
จะไปเอาผลไม้มาให้
อ่าไปเก็บกล้วยเก็บอะไรมาให้นะคะเอ้อทำ
เหมือนนกเลยคะ
เราจะผิดไหมเนี่ย
โอเคโอเค
ที่นี้นี้คุณนิคืนนี้ขอบไผ่มีวันหนึ่งพ่อ
ฤาษีไปใช่ไหมคะอ่ะอยู่คนเดียวเป็นผู้หญิง
สวยนะคะก็มี
พระอินทร์ที่
More  in พระอินทร์
พระอินทร์สีเขียว
พระอินทร์ก็มา
มานางกาลอัจนาก็เห็นพระอินทร์เธออ๋อใช่
ไหมพระอินทร์ก็เห็นนางกาลอัจนากับลาก็นาง
กาลอัจนาก็สวยใช่ไหมนางกาลอัจนาก็โอ๊ะชอบ
พระอินทร์
เฮ้ยการอาจจะนาไม่ใช่คนจริงๆเนาะก็ไม่
เข้าใจผิดถูกมาหากับๆงานการอัดพระอินทร์
ก็คิด
[เพลง]
นนทกลงมา Story ที่แล้วนะคะนนทกลงมาเป็น
ยักษ์คือมีอำนาจจับนักเรียนอย่าลืมไปดู
คลิปนนทกนะคะที่แล้วนะว่านนทกคือตั้งค่า
พระอินทร์ก็อยากจะให้ตัวเองลงมาช่วย 3
ช่วยโอเคช่วยช่วยโลกสิลูกครับเพราะว่าจะ
มียักษ์น่ากลัว
พระอินทร์ก็เลยโอเค
ทำให้นางกาลอัจนาน่ะท้อง
ก็ The นะเพราะว่านางจานอาจจะนานเนี่ย
ท้องมีรูปกับพระฤาษีแล้ว
แล้ว
ให้อินก่อนกับนางกาลอัจนาก็รักกันแล้วก็
ท้องอีกมากอ่าเค้าเข้า The นะอะ
รักกันแล้วก็ไปเออไปถ้าเรื่องสีกลับมาก็
ไม่รู้
ก็ไม่รู้โอเคโอเคไม่รู้ไม่รู้ไม่รู้ก็เลย
สีเขียวปลาไม่รู้อะไรแต่ว่านางกาลอัจนา
เนี่ยก็ท้อง
พระฤาษีก็คิดลูกฉันใช่พกถ้าคุณอีกเป็นพระ
ฤาษีก็ไม่รู้ก็คิดว่าเออลูกเราสีเพราะว่า
เราต้อง
พระฤาษีมีภรรยา 1 คนพรรคระยะก็ต้องมีสามี
1 คนไม่บาปได้แล้วก็ที่ที่ภูเขาไม่มีคน
ใช่ไม่มีคนก็ต้องลูกเราพอนางกาญจนาท้อง
ท้องท้องท้องแล้วคลอดลูกเป็นผู้ชายครับ
ตัวสีเขียว
ตัวสีเขียวไชโย
โอ๊ยลูกค้ายเธอ
ได้สีเขียว
แล้วค่าในสีก็ไปเอาผลไม้ไปนั่งสมาธิไปอีก
ครับไม่อยู่บ้านนะครับเราไม่อยู่บ้านไป
อินไปแล้วใช่ไหมคะอะนกไปแล้ว
เห็นไหมอ่ะพระอาทิตย์มาค่ะครับ
พระอาทิตย์
พระอาทิตย์ก็เอาพระอาทิตย์ออกมา
นักเรียนคะอันนี้เป็นเป็น Story นะครับ
ว่าพระอาทิตย์หน้าจะมีเทพชื่อพระอาทิตย์
เอาพระอาทิตย์ออกมา
นางกาลอัจนาเนี่ยก็เห็นพระอาทิตย์
ก็ชอบอีกอ่ะใช่ไหมโอ๊ยโอ๊ยพระอาทิตย์ก็
ชอบก็คิดโอยอยากจะช่วยโลกให้สู้กับยักษ์
ได้ก็โอเคโอเคพระอาทิตย์ก็รักกับนางกาล
อัจนา
รับแล้วพระอาทิตย์ก็ขอโทษค่ะ
กาญจนาอยู่นี่
พระอาทิตย์แต่กูอะพระอาทิตย์ออกไปก่อนนะ
ฮะอาทิตย์ก็ไปให้อิ่มก็ไปใช่ไหมคะ
บ้านบ้านเข้าไป
โอเคอ่ะโอเคนะอ้าโอเคอ่ะงานการอาจจะพระ
ฤาษีกลับมา
ที่รู้ไม่รู้อีกแล้วพระฤาษี
นางการอ่านนะฮะก็ท้องอีก
โอเคโอเคแล้วก็มีลูก
ถ้าลูกชายลูกชายโอเคครับตัวสีสีแดงเออพระ
อาทิตย์สีแดงไงอ้าฤาษีก็ไชโยลูกชายสี
เขียวรูปชายสีแดงระลูกชาย
นางสวาหะเนี่ยคุณเอ็กซ์
ไม่ชอบใช่ไหม
หือโกรธเลยนะโปรดสิคือปกติอาหารนักเรียน
คนไทยก็จะเมื่อก่อนนะก็ชอบลูกชายเขาครับ
นางสวาหะก็โกรธทำไมพ่อไม่รักสวรรค์หัด
มั้ยกอดไม่อุ่น
แต่ก่อนอยากกอดอ่ะ
ลูกชายสีเขียวกับลูกชายสีแดง
สวาหะเนี่ยเห็นแล้วก็รู้ว่าไม่ใช่ลูกของ
สีสี
โค้กอูนิก็หมดหน้าหมดเวลาไม่เกิดเลย
ไว้เราต้องมาคุยกันใหม่ใน
วีดีโอต่อไปละและนักเรียนขอโทษผู้หมดเวลา
หมดเวลาใกล้ๆแต่เป็นเพื่อนพี่สะดุกเป็น
เรื่องที่สนุกนักเรียนต้องติดตามดูว่า
เรื่องจะเป็นยังไงเพราะตอนนี้เนี่ยนาง
สวาหะแบบโกรธนะฮะมันโกรธใช่ไหมคะกำลังตด
เกิดอะไรขึ้นนะคะสีรู้ไหมลูกศิษย์สีเขียว
กับสีแดงไม่ใช่ลูกตัวเองต้องมารอดูกันนะ
เนื้อหาอะไรครับไว้พบกันใหม่นะคะสวัสดี
ครับครูเอ๋สวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะวันนี้นะคะ
สวัสดีครับ